do you believe that characters Drive
plot no I think character character is
definitely Drive plot
um it's because
what we're showing what we're telling
you know uh we're showing like these
characters like their reaction to what's
happening
around them what's happening to them
right
um I feel I feel like if you have it the
other way around it's just you know so
contrived you know it's like you don't
you want something to happen to a
character and based on who that
character is
they respond and then that response
leads to the next action it leads to the
next thing you know you don't want to
have to just hit certain plot points
because it's mandated you know oh you
know I want to have uh uh Jim and George
fight
because the plot demands it no they have
to fight because there's there's an
actual conflict between these two
characters Jim did something that George
didn't like and because of George's
character you know he's going to react
in say a physical way right
um it has to be natural it has to be
organic so character definitely
definitely drives the plot
so one character whether it's in your
screenplays or your books that you were
very precious about and it was hard for
you to let bad things happen to oh that
that's all the time
that happens to so many of my characters
[Laughter]
um yeah actually
um in Potter's field uh there's a
character and I
I'm not gonna go into detail because I
don't want it to be ruined but there I
will say there's a character that I held
on to for a very long time I mean
through numerous drafts this was a
character that
essentially lived to the end of the
script uh just because I thought it was
cool and funny and yeah I thought it
worked but then I realized that
this poor character had to had to go and
I think that the story
um
it works better because of it
so yeah yeah I mean it but even in like
the romantic comedy you know I I have
bad things happen to you know characters
that I but you know here's the funny
thing I think that the worst things
happen to the characters that I love the
most
[Music]
um
because I want I think I want the
audience to really feel for those
characters like those are the cat you
know you want to come away say oh wow
you know like that hurt my heart or I
can't believe that that happened you
know to this person and
interesting so if you if it's not a
character that you really are invested
in maybe the stuff that happens is just
minor uh I mean I guess you know
relatively speaking you know you could
say that I mean I'm invested in all of
my characters I love I love all of my
characters I mean there are some that I
love more than others but I mean I I do
love all of my characters and so um
you know I I do want that
that feeling for all of them I want the
audience to to care for all of them so
even the bad ones you know I even give
the bad ones you know the villains or
you know the monsters I even give them
moments where it's like all right
you know I might not really like that
person but I understand you know or I
can you know
some way you know empathize with them
I mean Potter's field
we've got these these Undead creatures
running around but
you know they're monsters but you feel
for them because you you learn what
happened to them
you see so
what advice do you have for writing the
antagonist
they can't be
just like
cookie cutter
one-dimensional monsters you got to give
them some depth you know uh one of the
things I I don't remember where I first
heard it but you know the antagonist is
the protagonist of Their Own Story
they believe that they are the good guy
you know even something Thanos for
instance uh uh with the Avengers
clearly he's the bad guy he wants to
decimate all life or half you know of
all life in the universe but he believes
he's doing uh he believes he's doing
something Noble
and that's the thing you you have to you
have to give your villain these layers
you have to give your antagonists these
layers make them believe that
what they're doing is the right thing or
that they've got I don't want to say
Noble reasons
um but that they've in their mind the
reasons for their actions are Justified
in Real Genius to to do we see that in
this professor
huh
interestingly enough I think that the
professor is pretty he's pretty
one-dimensional to be honest because his
goal is just to sell
this uh this laser this technology to
the government
uh but you know what we do we do get
some layers like you know we learned
that he hates popcorn it's a small thing
but it plays out in the end
um
we also learned that
he sleeps with his students
you know he has he has a fling with one
of his young students
um so there are little little you know
pieces here and there but
yeah I don't
I don't know that
I don't know that we would root for him
I tell you though who we would root for
in Real Genius that could be considered
villainous which would be Kent the bully
who's essentially the professor's
underling like I think he's like the TA
or whatever
um ultimately Kent just wants to be
liked he wants to be accepted by the
cool kids
and that comes out so if we're you know
if we're looking for a villain example
in Real Genius I would say it's him you
know he's doing all the things that he
thinks will
will make him popular
you know he'll be liked he'll also
please the professor because he wants to
do that
he thinks he's doing all the right
things for all the right reasons you
know
and in the end in a weird kind of way he
gets accepted by
Our Heroes you know he's embraced by
them and it's yeah
so he's redeemable in some sense whereas
the professor character
is just all we know about him is just he
makes horrible choices right yeah okay
and he feels No Remorse for them right
right
what mistakes do writers make in writing
their characters
um
I think that
one big mistake is trying to
recreate something
or recreate a character that they've
seen elsewhere right
it's great to draw inspiration from you
know as I mentioned my protagonist in
Potter's field you know is inspired by
Eddie Murphy but I wasn't trying to
recreate like I wasn't recreating Reggie
Hammond from 48 Hours you know I was
taking elements that I thought worked
for that character and seeing how they
could work for my character but I think
that a lot of writers try to recreate
characters wholesale and you can't do
that you know you have to you have to
find something unique
about your characters and I think that
that uniqueness comes from within
you know you have to this kind of goes
back to why I think I love all of my
characters is because every character
that I write
has a piece of me
and
I know that that's probably cliche but I
mean like really have a piece of me like
there's always some aspect about these
characters that's an aspect
of me
uh and I think that that's what a lot of
writers
should do is they need to find like
those aspects that they can imbue in
their characters to make the characters
more unique
so if I'm a writer that's so inspired by
a story and I want to make
something so similar it would be better
if I just did a fan fiction
maybe story based on this rather than
try to infuse that same kind of
character into my own world you know
that's the thing if if you're if you're
trying to tell an original story no
create that character like you know
create that original character
can be inspired by you know like
whatever but imbue that character with
with with your uniqueness if you're
writing fan fiction you're trying to
play in somebody else's sandbox there's
nothing wrong with that I think that
that's great but
you're you're dealing with you're
dealing with a world and you're dealing
with uh characters and relationships and
things that have already been
established even if you create like a
new like if I'm writing Star Wars fanfic
and I create a whole new Jedi character
to throw into that fanfic I'm still
dealing with the world that was created
by Lucas and that's been shepherded by
you know so many others
um
but if if if if you want to create like
a truly original character you've got to
tell your own story
and I think that
in putting yourself in your characters
and making your characters unique like
that's that's really telling your story
that's really telling your truth because
this is coming from you as opposed to
working within parameters that have
already been established you see what
I'm saying
what questions should a writer be asking
themselves about their characters
what makes their character tick why
is this character doing what they're
doing
um
when a character every story is about a
character that wants something
why does that character want it
um you think of the opposing forces to
getting what you want why are those the
opposing forces that give your character
a hard time
you know
um just you gotta you've gotta really
put yourself in
in your character's place like you know
what can you do how can you navigate
this world and and these obstacles in
order to get what you want
um this is why I say you have to imbue
like you know
a portion of you
because
this is going to be like this is you as
as a writer
you are going on this journey along with
your protagonist
you are the protagonist essentially
right so
what would you do how can you face these
obstacles how can you face
whatever adversaries you know come your
way
um in order to achieve that goal
why is that goal so important
that you would
endure like you know uh all this
conflict
and to remember that the antagonist is
the protagonist of their own of Their
Own Story right right
what suggestions do you have for writers
developing character I would say that
writers definitely need to know
themselves
so that they can
dig deep
um
but also I would suggest writers pay
attention to
those around them
uh whereas you know I'd like to give my
characters characteristics of me
I also draw inspiration from
people I've met my friends my family
um and and I think I think that that's
really important because when you pay
attention to other people you know you
just kind of pick up on
everything about them uh from you know
the way they speak the way they carry
themselves like their posture or
whatever
um even little decisions will in inform
you you know tell you so much about a
person you know whether they take sugar
in their coffee or or not you know which
then you know it can lead you down to
rabbit holes just like well why doesn't
she take sugar in her coffee you know
that's that's an interesting choice you
know and you can just go so many places
um but I think that paying attention to
other people is is really key uh to
developing
a wide variety of characters
we find that something when you're out
in the world that you are constantly
sort of observing just to see from a
character's perspective not necessarily
like judging someone but just just
sinking in how someone's approaching the
Barista and asking maybe they're
Whispering for their
and we don't know why there was
right right no absolutely you know and
that's that's a great example because
that's a choice that's a choice that
that person made was to whisper to the
Barista as opposed to you know just
loudly you know yes I would like a Fenty
whatever
you know and and those choices
informed character so yeah you're
absolutely right that's yeah
so I'm always intrigued by people that
are really picky about their orders and
they're they're very like specific and
they seem very concerned and I remember
we went to some place where the man
wanted to watch them cut up the pizza at
one of these pizza and I know this seems
trivial but to me it spoke volumes about
who this guy was and they weren't
cutting it up right and he was upset
this was just one of these made so you
just then wonder what is his life like
outside of that pizza place exactly if
he was so concerned with the way they
were cutting the pizza and this is one
of these made order places it's not even
like you know I mean people it's it's
quick fast you know and so just just
watching little interactions like that
yeah